hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter four of book five of theodore
dostoevsky's the brothers kara mazoff
there is a conversation
being held between two of the brothers
karamazov
ivan and aliyosha and eliosha is the
younger brother who is training to be
a monk and ivan does most of the talking
in part because ivan is the one making
a certain kind of case laying out a
problematic and it revolves around
the suffering of children
there are some general points that ivan
makes here
which i think you could say ivan you
know you can't always say that
that a dostoevsky in character is
speaking for dostoevsky
but i think at this point you can say
that he really is
and so there's there's three main
general points that are leading into
this this
whatever we want to call it argument
complaint
prelude to the poem that follows in the
next chapter
and ivan's first point is that
the argument that he's going to make or
the case that he's going to make
which has to do with why it's hard
almost impossible to follow the
commandment of loving one's neighbor
is going to be focused
here on the suffering of children
he says i meant to talk about the
suffering of mankind in general
but better let us dwell only on the
suffering of children
that will reduce the scope of my
argument about 10 times but even so it's
better if we
keep to children and you might say
well okay so why is this reducing the
scope
of the argument our children only
one-tenth of the population
you know they're probably more than that
i don't think we have to worry so much
about the number
and i think quite honestly that
ivan as the character doesn't really
think
that this reduces the scope of the
argument at all
as a matter of fact it concentrates it
in its weakest point
you know the place where the divine plan
or cosmic justice or whatever it's going
to be
is most easy to attack the suffering of
children you know he he tells us when it
comes to it
that um he says i could never understood
how it's possible to love one's neighbor
and it's
it's precisely one's neighbors one
cannot possibly
uh love uh most of them are are terrible
people that that you know or even if
they're not it's hard to
to care for them and love them and he he
says that
the question is whether this comes from
bad qualities in people or is inherent
in their nature in my opinion christ's
love for people is
it's kind a miracle impossible on earth
true he was god but we are not gods
let's say that i for example i'm capable
of profound suffering
but another man will never be able to
know the degree of my suffering because
he's another and not me
and he goes on and on he says we don't
help each other out we we often don't
care about each other's suffering
or we'll alleviate it in one way but not
alleviated in another and if somebody
says something about it will take it all
away
that's for adults and as ivan points out
this is the second point
we might actually say adults have it
coming
here he says i'm not going to talk about
grown-ups apart from the fact they are
disgusting and don't deserve
love they also have retribution meaning
they
have it coming to them they ate the
apple a new good and evil and became
as gods now of course this is a
reference to the biblical
account in genesis of adam and eve
eating the forbidden fruit wasn't
necessarily an
apple it just says fruit and
becoming knowledgeable about good and
evil
and obviously we don't as adults come to
some point in our life where we bite
into an apple and suddenly we know
everything rather we become rational
beings
at whatever age the age of reason
happens to be
might be later for some it might be
earlier for some maybe some people never
really
attain it because of some damage to
themselves
but um adults can be blamed for being
the jerks for being the
bastards that they they are even if
they're good adults they're going to
have some
some flaws they're bearing the weight
of some sort of primal guilt upon them
but children ivan says
children don't bear that he says little
children have not eaten anything
and are not yet guilty of anything and
you might say well wait a second what
about little devil children
or sociopaths or rotten kids you know
they hurt animals they hurt other kids
they bully them
they do all sorts of awful things right
and he's not he's not
saying that that's not the case maybe
you put those kids over here to the side
there's still kids who are not yet
guilty
who still suffer
because of what other people impose upon
them
not just suffering because of the the
nature of the world or
you know a disease like leukemia they
suffer because
agents who decide to make them suffer
impose that
upon them for whatever reason that they
do
the third thing uh well here i want to
read one other passage
says children while they're still
children up to the age of seven for
example
are terribly remote from grown-up people
as if they were different beings of a
different
nature so you know that he's not saying
children who are
14 or something like that he's talking
about little kids
the other thing that he says in
considering one of the
cases that we're going to talk about in
a moment
is it's the vulnerability of the child
that in some way tempts or attracts
the abuser he says
here we go um this love
of torturing children but only children
is a peculiar quality that exists in
much of mankind
these same torturers look upon other
examples of humankind even mildly and
benevolently
and but they have a great love of
torturing children
and he says what's going on there it is
precisely
the defenselessness of these creatures
that
tempts the torturers the angelic
trustfulness of the child
who has nowhere to turn and no one to
turn to
this is what inflames the vile blood of
the torture and then
dostoevsky goes on to say something
about what lies within
if not all of us at least most of us
something endemic to human nature
before that though let's dwell on these
these three things that he says
the defenselessness of these creatures
their vulnerability the angelic
trustfulness of the child when abuse is
taking place
it's not simply that organic damage
or psychological damage is being done
you know through what's being imposed on
the child
it's also that there is a breach of the
trust
that the child gives to the adult
which makes it even worse that's why
abuse can be so incredibly traumatic
the other thing he says the child has
nowhere to turn
and no one to turn to they are isolated
they are kept
stuck there in the situation
of abuse so what does
those dostoevsky speaking through ivan
conclude
he says there is a beast hidden in every
man a beast of rage
a beast of sensual inflammability at the
cries of the tormented victim
an unrestrained beast let off the chain
a beast of diseases
acquired in debauchery so there's a lot
of ways of characterizing this
it's it's part of the ourselves that we
can never
fully get rid of in most cases
and have to keep a watch on because it's
so easy
and he talks about rage anger
is an emotion that blinds us
that leads us to go too far this is
something that the ancients knew
and wrote about quite a bit and that
continued on through all sorts of
spiritual literature
that alyosha himself would be conversant
with
this is in some respect talking about
what in in you know platonic accounts is
the thumatic
or one of the best translations in the
philocalia for this
the incandescent part of the soul left
to its own devices
it can lapse into horrible
cruelty and justify what it's doing
it can be driving and driven at the same
time
now he brings up several specific cases
and i think that we can use these you
know we can get away from the the
specifics and
say that there's some general points
here to
why dostoevsky is having ivan talk about
these
the first is the turks terrorizing the
slavs at the time that we're
looking at in this story the ottoman
empire still exists
and the ottoman empire is trying to
control its western provinces in the
balkans essentially through
terrorizing the non-muslim slavic
and they do so he mentions you know
raping
women and raping children but and also
engaging this horrible cruelty of taking
captives
nailing them by their ears to to fences
and then hanging them in the morning and
dostoevsky says that you know
we talk about you know animal cruelty or
beastial cruelty human beings can be
much more
cruel than mere beasts and so this is
being done essentially for a political
purpose but the people who are doing it
probably also get off on it as well the
soldiers
involved he talks about all sorts of
atrocities
uh you know cutting women's bellies open
and taking the babies out
uh you know throwing them up in the air
and stabbing them with bayonets
and there's a little passage there
about taking a a little infant and
putting a pistol in its face getting it
to treat it as as
if it's a toy and while the baby's
smiling shooting it in the face in front
of the mother
and dostoevsky has ivan say
the point of this is in fact to
terrorize it's done in front of the
mothers
that cruelty is is being done
to do something then there's another
sort of contrast talking about this
this sweet swiss kid richard who's an
illegitimate child
and gets given to some shepherds who
don't abuse him
all that much in the same way but they
totally neglect him they enforce the
neglect through
physical abuse when he wants to eat the
food that the pigs are being given
they beat him for that but for the most
part it's
it's indifference to his fate it's
nobody bringing him up it's
nobody helping him in any way including
the people he's surrounded by
in the town who don't care about him at
all
as a child and that's a that's another
mode of making children suffer
he talks also about the russians
preference for
beatings for the whip for the lash
for the the stick to to beat children
with
and also animals he dwells on this you
know
whipping of of the horse even aiming at
its eyes
you have to be particularly cruel to do
something like that
to an animal and it's also done to
children as well and he brings up cases
where a child is so badly beaten
that they suffer either terrible
injuries or die as a result and then the
parents
finally get drawn into court
and what happens there there's this
entire
indignation and defense on the part of
the parents who are you to tell me how
to discipline
my child where you know this is the
family keep the state
out of there and this still goes on
today we still see
parents imposing in our you know own
american nation there are news cases
that come to light of parents doing
terrible things to their children under
the the guise of discipline
we have entire camps that we send kids
to usually
outside of the country so that no state
or federal law
will apply to it where you know the kids
are going to be straightened out
and all that really happens is a lot of
beatings
this is a big problem right and this is
another
case of imposing cruelty
on children causing them suffer
suffering
for its own sake there's an even worse
case of the
five-year-old russian girl who is
locked into the outhouse i'm gonna read
this one these educated parents
subjected the poor
five-year-old girl to every possible
torture they
beat her flogged her kicked her not
knowing why themselves until her whole
body was nothing but bruises
finally they attained the height of
finesse in the freezing cold they locked
her all night in the outhouse
because she wouldn't ask to get up and
go in the middle of the night
as if a five-year-old child sleeping at
sound angelic sleep could have learned
to ask by that age
for that they smeared her face with her
excrement and made her eat the excrement
and it was her mother
who made her do that and this mother
could sleep while her poor child was
moaning all night
in that vile place this is
you know again horrific abuse we've had
cases
like that here in the united states
there was a famous case
in new york uh about i think 15 years
ago of something
very similar a similarly aged child
being locked in the basement being
beaten incessantly smeared with
excrement
made to eat her own excrement while her
mother and boyfriend
were upstairs who eventually died of her
injuries
while the other children of those two
played above if i remember right and
there's case after case
after case like this all you have to do
is actually open your eyes
and read you know the the newspapers or
police blotters or
things like that and and these will come
to light and you'll be
shocked at how how many cases there are
like this and then horrified by the idea
that these are just the tip of the
iceberg the ones that have actually come
to light
there's also this other case of the boy
and
he's a surf meaning essentially a slave
living on the estate of this general
and he happens to injure the general's
favorite dog
not in a terrible way but the dog is
limping so the general says
who lamed my dog they point out the kid
he is taken held overnight brought out
stripped in front of all the other serfs
including his mother
sent to run and then they sick the dogs
on him and they tear him apart
alive again massive
horrible cruelty that's being done and
is there any any recourse
the general uh was later declared
incompetent to administer his estates
and you know he actually asked eliosha
what should be done with him
shoot him shoot him for moral
satisfaction and ali osha does say
yeah shoot him and there is something
within us that i think responds to this
saying yeah there's there should be some
sort of
penalty some sort of retribution some
sort of payback
but this is where we get to the scandal
nothing you could do would actually
fix what's what's been done to the child
in some cases the child's dead
or so damaged by the trauma that's been
inflicted upon them this is a scandal
and and we have to be very careful when
we use this word scandal because it has
been somewhat
debased i would say you know we talk
about people having
politicians having scandals and you know
if it's a real scandal
they should be like totally gone because
a scandal means a stumbling block
you find it for example in the new
testament when christ
tells those around him don't let anyone
scandalize these little children
because if if they do it would be better
for that person to have a millstone
tied around their neck and be thrown in
the sea meaning it is really bad
to scandalize them what is a scandal
it's a stumbling block it's an
impediment
you know when we tell people for example
you know god is our heavenly father
well if your own father is a complete
prick who abuses you all the time that's
a scandal
because if we're going to say that god
is a heavenly father then you're like
well
i don't want anything to do with that
person right it it prevents us from
doing things there are so many
different ways that people can be
scandalized
and for ivan this suffering of children
leads to his own sort of scandalization
he says
there's there's no redeeming quality
to this it doesn't help the universe in
any way it's not part of some
universal harmony and he says that
i don't want harmony for love of mankind
i don't want it
i want to remain with unrequited
suffering and my
unquenched indignation even if i'm wrong
they've put too high a price on harmony
we can't afford to pay for such an
admission i hasten to return my ticket
he says i don't it's not that i don't
accept god alyosha
i just most respectfully return him
the ticket i can't accept this
as a just world in which there is so
much
suffering not just for humanity in
general
but for children
you